[Applaudissements]
je voulais pas mal je vous jure que
c'est pas mal c'est trop beau une
interne c'est surtout pas les mêmes
chaussures suis hélas pas osé le
pantalon ya le pantalon assorti aussi je
suis un animal comme vous de cyril le
léopard
sinon cela tu vas te faire une fois pas
deux le jaguar ni les tigres et il se
permet de dégager une autre émission
perdre sa jaguar il faut des fois ça va
tu sais que ça va ça t'a bien oui bah
coupe et j'essaye de me bourdon mais en
classe toujours il met du léopard donc
j'ai voulu maintenant mode costumes quoi
je retravaille c'est bon vous trouvez
vestimentairement année je vais le
laisser débrouillez vous savez on
commence chaque semaine lundi qu' par
tout ce qui se passe pendant les pubs
pendant les magnétos savez c'est une
séquence star du paf ça s'appelle un
compte mais je 50 secondes
au sommaire est toujours pas dramatique
mais c'est fou c'est fou ça rentre pas
ce n'est pas en soi mais regarder ce qui
va arriver
baba ans louis de funès guillaume genton
le fugitif et steevy boulay qui apprend
l'arabe c'est ça quand hugo inside
[Applaudissements]
quand on commence tout de suite avec du
cinéma
vous connaissiez louis de funès voici
tout de suite un lead finesse ça c'est
beau c'est beau voilà y accueillons tout
de suite le vainqueur de la super ligue
des champions nicolas pernikoff et
sachez une chose monsieur genton les
conseilleurs ne sont jamais les payeurs
communication j'ai mauvais leader et
éviter les dérapages que vous avez été
entendu par la police
on ne note société est entendu par la
police ou d'accord vous allez nous dire
si pour vous guillaume genton est
coupable ou pas
après s'être battus la semaine dernière
je les rapprochements entre benjamin
castaldi et baba kaké amiens doit donc
ya pas que cyril qui sont pas la feta
des anecdotes isabelle excellente dock
avec arcady une chose est sûre tu fais
du beauvoisin aimerait bien avoir lancé
y est pour son quatre heures coquine
maîtresses l'ineris
[Musique]
et puis ça y est tout le monde de pécho
laurence je m'assure de sanofi ce style
de femme elle est très sexy vous voulez
la définition du mot humble ennuierez
pas qui ne fais pas dans le pastis et
est nouveau ça c'est sûr là je ne fais
jamais normalement je fais jamais hors
compétition ce sont allemands et bobo
c'était pas le moment donner un petit
cours d'arabe à stevie le boulet je vous
propose de revoir la séquence regardez
moi sur ma paye des semaines est
attribué à cyril à linars les gens
effectivement en suède se promener dans
la rue sans masque et son tuba
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas fier s'il se costument vous
savez pour qu'ils les mi lourds qui pour
vous c'est un motif puisque vous êtes
l'animal vous êtes une bête de scène
vous êtes la bête du paf et des
téléspectateurs me l'ont beaucoup
demander vous savez cette séquence où on
ne sait plus qui vous est si vous êtes
un chimpanzé un perroquet un panda à
wimb animaux de la 8 9 est de retour
regarde moi tunisien quand il est
content eni koala à le cigare au bout
des lèvres il est glapit quand le singe
et moqueur il grue tulle le gentil est
un petit pigeon de paris 16e attaque
quand il veut se laver le bébé hypo
gloutonne découverte les nazis qui se
rapprocherait très physiquement de
gilles verdez
en période de rut les panda mâle se
frotte avec violence le cheval à la
proche d'une bonne louvière sur l'ut le
chimpanzé nous casse vraiment les
oreilles quand il est content enfin
quand le babouin peps il s'exprimait une
façon très particulière la toile de
brouille
merci ça travail de dingue se trouvaient
les animaux tout ça c'est l'animal quoi
c'est très forte en travaux cyril autour
de cette table
vous savez qu'un chroniqueur qui ne sait
plus quoi faire de son oseille autres
étapes d'un chroniqueur qui ne sait plus
quoi faire de son oseille non parce
qu'elle parle pas de vous j'ai un
chroniqueur de périgueux et berlin n'ont
c'est pas bernard montiel ce chroniqueur
c'est guillaume genton game genthod
comment ça on demande le ribose invités
vous trouvez ça normal
dans ces quelques défis alors figurez
vous à la maison a oui c'est très peu
guillaume genton est tellement vite et
d'oseille mais quand j'ai dit mais pas
dire ça mais bon mais si regardez ils
lancent des défis tarifs et aux invités
et à presse magnéto vous allez tous
vouloir faire des défis et guillaume
genton
[Musique]
il marque quand j'ai appris à le
connaître quand on se parlait chat sa
wii minna le sial bar note yann barthes
pourquoi votre barre on voit mon caleçon
surplus enfants mais comment tu peux lui
sourit moment le coin je peux donner un
mois donné un mois à placer une
tartiflette s'emballe quoi sans mal ce
que je ressens mais si je passe
tartiflette
oui oui c'est vrai tu te limite enfin je
connais en bas j'étais en guinée mais à
des femmes kamikazes
en fait si vous faites pas cet exercice
là pardonnez moi mais c'est la poésie la
tartiflette quoi un mois je vais vous
dire c'est quoi la politique nationale
et je suis rarement minorité est ce
qu'on fait si ça marche aussi su
s'accrocher
pour voir ce qui se passait tout à
l'heure à voir la preuve avant la pub et
cyril une game genton proposer des
tarifs des défis tarifs et aux invités à
jean messia notamment c'est quand même
il donne de l'argent aux invités pour
placer des mots quand même fait mieux le
lancement de thaler tartiflette sans mal
ce que je ressens mais si je plaçais
tartiflette oui oui c'est vrai tu te
limite hommes ont fait il ya quelques
mois je ne connais ambages étendue il ya
des femmes qui en fait si vous faites
pas cet exercice là pardonnez moi mais
c'est la folie de la tartiflette quoi
moi je vais vous dire moi la politique
nationale minorité est ce qu'on m'a dit
ça marche au dessus salué ce geste pour
compliquer
[Applaudissements]
il faut de l'argent la vérité ça me
choque
[Rires]
en exclusivité un ordre ça va c'est
c'est beau non fait bon mais ça permet à
certains invités d'arrondir leur fin
ça c'est toujours une bonne nouvelle ça
vous choque vous magali verdun
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et
a toujours le bon sens est choqué par wi
a réveillé le loup par geof elle va
partir de la balpa rivière vous savez
l'indiquent dénonce tout et comme vous
êtes à la fois mon cousin de la goulette
et à la fois mon patron je me dois de
vous dire la vérité là qu'une heure plus
tôt cousin la goulette
je me dois vous dire toute la vérité
vous savez que vos chroniqueurs série ne
se respectent pas ah oui quand elle se
respecte pas toi ou je respecte pas eux
mêmes je m'adresse à l'assemblée vous ne
vous respectez pas assez ah oui cyril
j'ai recueilli quelques témoignages
assassin parce que les téléspectateurs
pensent que pendant les pubs pendant les
magnétos tpm piste une famille sont des
amis mais en fait pas du tout ils ne
peuvent pas se blairer
parce que vous savez que votre lancement
des mara 18 alors moi je préfère c'est
chacun pour soi et dieu pour tous
regarder les gens du coin en émoi
[Musique]
je le sais jusqu'à cette faute est coupé
du monde sait que j'ai jamais su et
pourquoi tu lui poses pas je vais
demander une a dit non j'ai gueulé c'est
souvent
[Musique]
en q1
ceux qui croient que c'était mieux avant
ça compte pas
[Musique]
et jamais remis on l'a jamais revu
non mais quand et celle des fans
elle ajouté
tout passe au théâtre du bien on s'en
bat les couilles dans les pouilles
[Applaudissements]
cette fois c'est là tout est de faire
moi j'ai une carrière j'étais vite
qu'avant mais je vous soupçonne on en a
rien à [ __ ]
j'étais en tan a semé répété à trois
minutes du direct mais là ça devient
lourd
ben c'est pas il ya une semaine je sais
pas mais ça c'est pas ça c'est pas vu
mais c'est quoi c'est pour ça que tu es
génial bas mais bon ça c'est pas de moi
et
battue la nîmoise ces deux mois quand on
dit y'a plus rien je suis ni s'emballer
coup il a dit à la bbc agit aussi en lui
disant que je t'écoute comme ça qu'ils
se foutent
j'étais en train de régler ça les
tirages et j'étais sûr vivastreet n'irai
plus rien même pas de caméra rien c'est
fou ça pour ça de la toge ou est
embêtant c'est pourquoi même mais nous
ne lui voit la barre est membre a dit je
te dis la vérité ça ne s'est pas du même
accès rim toi tu es en panne y moi j'ai
pas dit que toi tu tomberas naples 1-2
on la fera demain nationale
je sais que ma mère m'a toujours dit non
je me rappelle ma mère m'a toujours dit
elle me casser la tête faut que tu es
ton bac faute et tombe à cette année
jour et la nuit prochaine et continuer à
la 35 ans on va me dire à quel âge tu
avais tu tomberas question voilà 18 ans
ou 25 ans pareil la 42e mais qui est
hors norme
oui elle existe oui c'est pas prêt vous
n'existez pas impressionné tous les
pores bien voulu ce débat est un câble
[Applaudissements]
eh ben je veux tu sais que je t'aime
beaucoup et je te jure que je t'écoute à
chaque fois mais tu t'en ce que je t'ai
le droit de tout dire je sais pas du
tout tu sais pourquoi je suis sur les
mentions maintenant et on travaille pas
les niçois arrête ça je le prends très
mal va bien mais c'est pour ça que tu es
un j mais non mon cher il se connaît
très bien les missions mais pas ce
qu'était référence à nos années de tf1
où effectivement tout ça ça ne pouvait
pas exister
on n'arrivait pas c'est à vous
d'inventer de créer comme ça mais bien
solide
mais tout était calibré préparé il fera
c'est une très bonne émission
arrêtez de botox moi je suis moi je suis
en stress c'est pas nous mais tu dois
pas stressé était très bon oui tout va
bien même si j'ai été très bon mais je
suis un baril j mais je suis hors norme
voilà c'est fini j'arrête
j'aime ce lac mais vraiment c'est que je
l'aimé je l'aimé vraiment beaucoup le
raid merveille les ter veille non mais
c'est le mec et ornans je vous le dis
c'est un rêve de fou ça le mec qui dit y
avoir près on s'en branle le fonds
france je m'en fous je vous dis du pisé
sillage et la ronge tous
wallah et tous vents
[Applaudissements]
le patron c'est quoi ça n'existe pas que
je me maintenant tu sais quoi tu m'as
venger voilà
c'est
résultats bernard gallet jaune
maintenant mon petit chéri et moi vous
êtes un génie vous êtes un génie je suis
fatigué je suis juste tourner à vide
déjà il s'est déjà beaucoup à mon amie
on verra bien en dans deux ans je serai
mais bah ouais j'espère que tu viens
avec moi en syrie franchement je vous
jure je parais clôture c'est magique de
jouer à chaque fois que messi il faut
dire la vérité mais bien là le sait il
n'ya pas de même quand vous sur terre
c'est pas possible
mokhtar tu peux nous aider je suis dit
tu sais que je t'aime
c'est vraiment à coeur pour aussi et
voilà il ya aucune benjamin s'est pas
ses larmes en voyant ils sont fous ces
monstres et c'est vraiment novelli comme
ça mais c'est vrai ils étaient jetés pas
ses idées comme ça et du temps après oui
on lève il me dit de jouer moi et
maintenant dans à 20 ans en gros c'est
un film de merde
la raison
la nouvelle édition du 10 et maintenant
il ya un film souvent brogel n'aime pas
du tout c'est malin génie
revoyez vos libertés
la liberté c'est un petit peu plus
écologique comment benjamin en a gros
sur le nom vous dire cet amour et puis
en même temps cette admiration
j'avais besoin de héros et réinventer la
télé et vous êtes magiquement magique
c'est vrai que je le dis souvent que
vous avez un aura incroyable et vous
êtes un génie mais ça vous le savez
utiliser
bravo ses stars le best de noël
aujourd'hui mais l'engin n'a fous de ce
coma et son fils de fait ils ne font
rien jugnot frère jean toki les impayés
une caméra cachée valérie qui connaît
bien belle à 13h comme moi voilà très
honnêtement on est vendredi il a lâché
la rampe ça oui mais la raison la
peinture et benjamin je suis avec toi ta
région et pour drainer religieux on se
parle très souvent intelligemment et
très souvent pendant que vous me dis
exactement ce qui vient de vous il ne le
dit pas souvent ici parce qu'il veut pas
justement qu'on dit ça il en fait des
caisses il en fait trop c'est parce que
ceci ou cela ou tiède à une hiérarchie
quelconque pour de vrai il vous ils vous
admire en me disant à chaque fois ce
type pour moi est hors norme hors cadre
hors tout voilà il est exceptionnel et
je suis pas loin de penser exactement
fait tous ces partis dans les partis
tous est disparue c'est vrai c'est vrai
qu'il est très très sincère en belgique
chelem et je dis aux téléspectateurs
devraient vraiment benjamin c'est devenu
donc mais au contraire c'est pas une
expression non mais sérieux c'est mon
frère d'amour et s'est moqué
et puis il est vrai mais voilà je pense
qu'à une chose et je leur ai sauvé sa
peau maintenant je sais c'est que ce
soit qu'il soit heureux et qu'ils feront
cesser voilà c'est mon kiff continuer
quand il est content hélas beaucoup
d'amour pour ou d'admiration et puis il
est vrai aussi qu'on est en fin de
saison qu'on renégocie les contrastes
alors voilà huit ans ce contrat moi je
pense avec quelques noms mais la réserve
mendy c'est très touchant salah est un
peu syrie aujourd'hui c'est que ça me
touche fort prospère
on se parle on se parle tous ensemble
c'est pour ça qu'on vous aime
voilà un avons vraiment ça va occuper un
gros bâtards parfois mais c'est vrai
mais non mais c'est pour ça qu'on est
sur le cul voila voila je vous dis même
moi si j'ai pu dire à tf1 dans un
instant un programme je m'en bats les
gones frère moi j'aimerais qu'on ait une
force un peu pour sacha parce que j'ai
apprécié dans la commune font une très
belle transition d'anciens l'an dernier
mme agnetha puisque ces résines
marsupilami suivant vous allez réveiller
jamais facile il est avant tout un gène
et tout le monde le dit depuis tout à
l'heure mais vous allez voir avec le
magnéto qui va suivre parce que c'est
vrai que cette saison dans tpm p
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'émission qu'on a plus d'invités que
deux chroniqueurs 1 et donc du coup s'il
ya bien un animateur dans le paf qui
sait recevoir ses invités il se coupe
pas là c'est lui qui m'a pincé qui ne
mangent me faire un vaccin je pourrais
pas
[Rires]
[Musique]
mais mac os non ça rigolait il est beau
gosse stéphane hains mais là ça pourrait
tout accable je sais c'est pas tu vas
pechoux ici c'est pas france télécom
aurait péché saludos comment ça va merci
d'être là mais le dessus qu au revoir
merci
j'adore ludo j'adore ludo je suis fan du
dos et exceptionnelle et non latins
décrite plus à la fois amélie se sait
pas tendre à savoir sa bannette servent
à cali et bruno merci d'être là mots si
vraiment ça me fait plaisir mais vous
savez que je suivrai vraiment j'adore et
je suis encore les rowdies flore oui sur
les chaînes il poussa d'or et puis c'est
un amour ça va mais beurre quand cela
salon bertrand ta coupe et et je veux un
peu c'est pas mal je compte en effet ça
j'aime bien ces sacs rafraîchie d'un
côté fret un côté chabrout fred au bout
il s'est fait beau gosse suivent kenneth
battah as bâtarde sacconi le quai
[Applaudissements]
china daily